Це вам, орки погані, за Вінницю! Вогонь!
Звичайний пікап, який перетворився на реактивну систему залпового вогню.
А ось ще нова, невипробувана в боях машина.
Військові називають "міні-Град", "міні-Хаймарс". У кожного своя, як позивний, так і назва машини.
Цю диво-зброю виготовили на заводі вінницької будівельної компанії.
Військові подали ідею волонтерам, ті придбали пікап, на підприємстві - зварили установку.
Станина наша, механізм, який піднімається і повертається.
А уже самі труби - це військових. Вони відвоювали їх у загарбників, "затрофеїли".
Ось так. … Тут так.
Коли летить снаряд, це дуже велике зусилля виходить.
І машину може перекинути просто.
Це збільшується її площу опирання, стійкості.
Точність стрільби такої установки, як у звичайного "Граду".
Дальність - до 20 кілометрів. Але у "міні-Граду" є безумовні переваги  - мобільність і малопомітність.
Він не такий шумний, як великі військові машини, може відстріляти до шести снарядів і швидко поїхати з позиції.
На підприємстві, де виготовили конструкцію, кожен п'ятий працівник нині у лавах ЗСУ.
Це мотивує тих, хто в тилу, працювати більше.
Підприємству, кожній людині, мені як директору важливо,
щоб мої люди повернулися якомога скоріше з перемогою живими. Не тільки мої, а всі.
І щоб у нас настав мир, щоб наші люди, діти не страждали, ті хто страждають.
Це вже другий "міні-Град", виготовлений на вінницькому заводі. З ним ще працюватимуть електрики.
А пусковий механізм поставлять самі військові, коли машина прибуде на фронт.
На вінницьких дорогах можна зустріти ще й такий автомобіль.
Це багі - всюдихід для військових.
Машину збирають буквально з нуля вінницькі автомайстри.
Ось це, наприклад, наполовину готовий автомобіль.
Це видаляємо. І це теж видаляємо.
Зараз ми займаємося обшивкою, закінчимо обшивку -
віддаємо на порошкове фарбування все, що підлягатиме фарбуванню, потім збираємо. Це готова рама.
Юрій сам розробив конструкцію цього автомобіля.
Двигун, гальма, рульову систему - бере із сертифікованих машин-донорів.
Усе збирають три-чотири майстри, у вільний від роботи час.
Ця машина має спроможність на пересіченій місцевості рухатися з великою швидкістю.
Вона пристосована для цього. Вона відносно легка, у неї потужна підвіска з великими ходами підвіски, потужний мотор.
У нас мотор 200 сил стоїть, дизельний.
Такий багі витримує різні навантаження: може транспортувати зброю, вивозити поранених з поля бою.
Двері - знімаються, лобове скло - відхиляється - так з машини можна вести розвідку чи й вогонь.
Це вже далеко не перша машина, за проханнями військових модель вдосконалювали.
Але перед відправленням на фронт її обов'язково обкатують.
Машина дійсно всюдихід, куди бачить - туди і їде!
Юрій вчився на автоконструктора, нині займається ремонтом автівок.
Усе життя чоловік захоплювався багі, займався автокросом на таких машинах.
Нині ж хобі перетворилося на обов'язок.
Хочеш - не хочеш, але якщо можеш… а я це можу, я вчився на це діло, усе життя займаюся ним.
Тому якщо я можу зробити, значить, це треба зробити.
Цей охайний гараж в селі за містом - ще одне "підприємство" вінницького "оборонпрому".
Його власник Володимир колись виготовляв ворота і хвіртки.
Тепер робить станки для кулеметів.
Станина під великокаліберний кулемет. Використовується вона як мобільна.
Багато "лендлізу" в нас є, розумієте, кацапського. Тому багато їх знімають з техніки просто.
А коли його зняти, де він стоїть, - він без нічого. Він якби голий.
Тому під нього треба, щоб користуватися, оце все.
Володимир працює над станками з 2016 року.
Скільки їх зробив - уже збився з ліку.
Але військові завжди просять більше.
Замість грошей Володимир за роботу отримує дещо інше.
Душами забираю… Раніше ми на кожній станині писали ціну.
А зараз я уже навіть не знаю. Ми трохи збилися, і розцінки інакші.
Раніше брали два-півтора "сєпара".
Зараз тільки за таку треба 10 "орків" брати. Оце вся ціна…
"Міні-Гради", багі, станки - усе це організовує одна людина.
Волонтер Денис Романовський з 2015 року допомагає військовим.
За дев'ять років роботи вже в мене в контактах приблизно 3600 осіб.
Я половини навіть не пам'ятаю, не знаю, але колись вони дзвонили,
записував в основному ім'я-батальйон, ім'я-бригада, ще місто. Дуже багато людей…
Денис зміг об'єднати десятки людей - своїх друзів, місцевий бізнес, депутатів.
Головний принцип - його майстри "волонтерять" у вільний від роботи час, аби мати змогу заробляти на життя.
Денис домовляється з меценатами, відкриває збори в соцмережах, закуповує матеріали,
приганяє автомобілі з Європи, сам їздить на фронт.
Усе це попри те, що кілька років тому втратив зір - через вроджену глаукому.
Ми можемо зробити це тут і зараз.
А державі, щоб зробити це треба пройти півроку усіх бюрократичних погоджень і так далі і тому подібне.
Ми сильні всі разом своїм колективом.
Якщо ми є в такому колективі, то не обов'язково бачити.
Головне - бажання робити. Голова є, руки-ноги є, можу дзвонити, говорити, свій сегмент робити.
Завдяки дружині возити, привозити, їздити на Донбас.
Є наш колектив. Це ж не я роблю один, чи хтось один.
У кожного свій сектор роботи, своя задача.
І ось такий комплекс роботи виходить через те, що це колектив.
Чоловік ще не знає, чим буде займатися після війни.
Міркує над тим, аби повернутися до юридичної справи - це його освіта.
Утім, поки і Денис, і його друзі прагнуть одного: зробити все, аби не залишити війну у спадок дітям.